you ready let's do it Jonathan major
Hollywood actor why did you decide you
wanted to talk now now his first
interview anywhere since being convicted
of assaulting his ex-girlfriend your
reaction to that verdict what does he
now want you to know the emotional
exclusive it's been it's been it's been
hard I'm sorry breaks this Monday
morning you think you'll ever work in
Hollywood again on ABC's Good Morning
America
so as you just saw Jonathan Majors is
going to be doing an interview with good
morning America this upcoming Monday
that will be January 8th which is
tomorrow and apparently he's going to be
talking about everything from being
arrested to going to court being found
guilty of assaulting his ex-girlfriend
Grace Jabari to getting fired by Marvel
Studios this is all apparently coming
out in this interview that is being
conducted by Good Morning America which
is very very interesting because Marvel
SL Disney are the ones who fired him yet
Disney owns Good Morning America Disney
is the parent company of ABC News and
Good Morning America so it's very
interesting that they would fire
Jonathan Majors but then allow him to
have his own segment on Good Morning
America his own interview talking about
everything that happened now of course
we're talking about this because it ties
into him being King the Conqueror or at
least he was King the Conqueror now
obviously he's not Marvel Studios says
fire him but one of the biggest
questions that people have been asking
since he was found guilty and since he
was fired by Marvel is what if he
appeals what if he appeals which he most
likely is going to and what if he wins
what if he appeals and brings up some
specific points or errors that might
have occurred in the trial and it turns
around they decide he's not guilty that
he didn't assault his ex-girlfriend
Grace Jabari or and I've even heard one
lawyer State this that if he did indeed
hurt her in trying to retrieve his phone
in New York that's actually according to
this lawyer under law allowed because
she took his property and he is allowed
to use forces to get that back full
disclosure I am not an attorney this is
something I saw an attorney say on the
news the point of mentioning that is
there are things that they could bring
up in this appeal to try and get the
Court's decision to be reversed and find
him not guilty so what happens then does
Marvel take him back does Marvel rehire
him they have done this before James gun
is the biggest example they fired him
but then they took him back and he went
on to continue to direct and write
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 so
Marvel has done it before who's to say
they can't do it again and what's
interesting is this interview is really
painting him out to be a victim here in
the clip the interviewer says why did
you decide to speak out now and the
narrator states that it's his first
interview after being convicted of
assaulting his ex-girlfriend but then
the narrator says what does he now want
you to know and they call it an
emotional exclusive interview and of
course this is put on by his PR team
right this is a part of the plan they
are trying to essentially do anything
and probably everything they can do to
save his career before he was even found
guilty he had been dropped by his
management company his PR Company he
lost commercial deals and ultimately he
went on to be fired by Marvel Studios so
obviously the trajectory here of his
career is that it is going away that
this is the end of his career so this is
definitely put on by his PR team to try
and Salvage anything that they possibly
can and tell his side of the story
because he never testified in court he
never said anything he didn't take the
stand not one time so now they're
basically stating that he's going to
tell us his side of the story and what
is the purpose of this well like I
mentioned it's to salvage his career and
I wouldn't be surprised if he actually
announces in this interview that he is
going to appeal but this segment this
interview is most likely to try and get
the Public's opinion kind of back to
favor him again he's most likely going
to talk about how his career has
essentially been ruined because of this
now the last question that the
interviewer asks is do you think you'll
ever work in Hollywood again which of
course we know he wants to he was in the
prime of his career when this all
happened playing the big bad of the
Multiverse Saga of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for Marvel Studios that's huge
Creed 3 was huge for him he was an Emy
nominee for Lovecraft country for
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
he was a nominee for the 2023 NAACP for
devotion his career was skyrocketing
before all of this went down in March so
really this is going to be kind of his
plea I believe to Hollywood to hear his
side of the story so he could eventually
go back and work as an actor again this
is clearly his passion this is clearly
what he has devoted his life to so it
makes sense that his PR team would do
this but again the only thing that
doesn't really make sense here is that
ABC Good Morning America is owned by
Disney so Disney is essentially giving
him a shot at this a shot at trying to
kind of get the public on his side
despite the fact that they fired him
they're still trying to give him a shot
at explaining his side of the story and
of course his reaction to the trial and
the arrest and everything because again
since he got arrested we really haven't
heard anything from him it's all come
from his legal team his lawyer was the
one that continued to state that he was
actually the victim in this but he
himself hasn't really spoken up so as
advertised in this Good Morning America
clip this is really going to be the
first time that he's spoken up about
this entire situation kind of since it's
happened and what's interesting is I've
heard a few people already mention this
online that this could be really a part
of Disney's plan so they could
ultimately go on later down the road to
recast him as king the Conqueror there
have been a lot of reports recently
stating that Marvel Studios is looking
to recast Jonathan major as king the
Conqueror which is obviously true but
we've heard a lot of reports recently
that state that Marvel Studios has
actors in mind who they want to play and
could have already possibly met with
them but Justin croll from deadline
tweeted this a couple of days ago on
January 5th he said see a lot of who
will play Kang next and here is a top
Contender for Kang comments this week
and all I'll say is this don't expect
that news anytime soon there will be
plenty of Marvel breaks in the coming
weeks on various fronts but don't hold
your breath on that one he continued to
State this isn't dismissing any rumor
this week about potential contenders for
the role I don't have any intel on those
being true or not true just letting you
know if I were betting what gets
announced first Kang or the field I'd
put money on the field so this week it
was announced that Coleman Domingo was
one of the potential actors that Marvel
Studios was looking at to replace
Jonathan major as Kang this is obviously
the other rumors that he was talking
about but from what he said based off of
what he seemingly know knows it sounds
like Marvel Studios isn't going to
recast anytime soon perhaps they are
giving this a little bit of time and
some of the speculation is right now is
that Disney again who owns Good Morning
America is giving him this opportunity
to share his side of the story to try to
get the public kind of to feel sorry for
him and maybe even a little bit on his
side that way if they do decide to
recast him as king the Conqueror at any
point in time they won't get that much
backlash for it and in fact maybe even
some people will well wcome him being
recast as king the Conqueror now having
said that it probably will only happen
if he appeals and ends up being found
not guilty if he doesn't appeal and
everything kind of stays as is Marvel
Studios most likely won't rehire him but
again A lot of people are really
pointing out the irony of essentially
Disney firing him but then allowing him
to tell his side of the story and it is
certainly interesting and I am very
curious to see what is going to be said
and what is going to come to light in
this interview that is going to happen
to I'll definitely be covering it so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on that video and of course we're doing
our monthly giveaway for chance to one
Xbox series X A PS5 Marvel Legends items
or some DC items all you got to do is
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof